in the last video I showed that a bunch
of triangles are similar to each other
to come up with a relationship between
the focal length the distance of an
object from the convex lenss
and the distance of the image of an
object from that convex lens and I
realized that there was one extra
low-hanging fruit based on all of the
geometry that I had done another
relationship that might come in useful
and that's the relationship between the
size of the object or maybe we since
it's an arrow here we call it the height
of the object and the height of the
image and the height of the image and we
did we really set up everything already
we already figured out that this
triangle over here this triangle over
here is similar to this triangle down
here and we figured out in the last
video that this triangle over here is
similar to this triangle over here and
since these two are similar we could say
that a is to V we did this over here
I'll rewrite it a is to B as a and both
of those are the the sides opposite the
right angles of these two similar
triangles so that's going to be the same
thing as the ratio of the sides opposite
this yellow angle opposite this yellow
angle right over here so in this
triangle over here since we started with
a first it's this height right over here
now what is this height right over here
this is the height of the object this is
the height of the object so this is the
height of the object is 2 now what is
this opposite side of this yellow angle
right over here well this is the height
of the image height of the image or we
know that from the last video the
distance of the object to the distance
of the image is the same thing as a to B
so this is going to be the same thing as
this so the ratio of the distances is
also the same thing as the ratio of
their heights so let me write it this
way so the ratio of the distance from
the object to the lens to the distance
of the from the image to the lens is the
same as the ratio of the height of the
object to the height of an image or to
the image of that object so I just
wanted to do that little low-hanging
there since we had already done all of
all of the we've set up all of the
mechanics already anyway hopefully you
found that useful